[Music]
[Music]
it's this moment isn't it I'm looking at
you and you look like a really nice
bunch there's been such great energy I
was sitting here for five minutes and it
just feels great this room and you look
really friendly enough for it so thank
you and you're looking a bit unsure you
know voice coach know where it's gonna
be fine
and I can see a couple of really brainy
Ted faces there and there's gonna be a
few ideas too but it is this moment this
moment ice our worlds are colliding
right now you're looking at me I'm
looking at you and it hits my brain with
a feeling of adrenaline accelerating
molecules you might say and different
people deal with this moment differently
some of us go hey you know there are
people who are confident they cope with
this moment it's totally fine and then
there are other people and not so
confident and it stops them speaking
this moment makes them feel anxious
makes them feel maybe they're not up to
it and that is not the case actually all
of us have confidence within and what I
want to talk about today is the idea
that we can find more confidence within
us if we know where to look and where do
we look we go within we look under the
bonnet and that's where we're going next
and the reason I want to talk about this
is because many years ago I stood in
front of an audience this big bigger at
Central Hall which is by the houses of
parliament really big Methodist space I
was super excited about that moment
because I knew that it was my big moment
as a rookie voice coach and that I was
gonna be able to speak and I stepped up
in front of that audience and what
happened was everything that could
possibly go wrong did I went too fast
I lost my words it felt like such a
horrible experience
and just as I thought it couldn't get
any worse the microphone broke and I
looked out across the room and I said in
my big voice coach voice there wasn't
this much wind at the time I have to say
and I said in my big voice coach voice
can you hear me at the back and someone
said Speak Up and I just felt this
feeling of absolute shame that feeling
of an audience looking at you and a
feeling of judgment which cripples us
and I left that venue and I thought to
myself never again now that clearly
didn't work as I'm here I also thought
I'm gonna do it differently next time
I'm gonna make sure that the next time I
stand up to speak it feels good and
where I had to go was within now we live
in a really visual culture we spend a
lot of time if we think about two worlds
we spend a lot of time thinking about
the outside maybe especially for women
and actually confidence doesn't exist on
the outside it exists within in the
visceral stuff in the bits within you
that we don't see and we're gonna go to
those bits and when I was thinking about
this idea three months ago when I got
asked to do it start to feel nervous
about this moment I started to think
about a quote that the director Peter
Brooke had said which is that we open
new drawers in the south and I started
to think about a chest of drawers and
then I came across this really cool
making called George McCallum he's
actually sitting there and I said to
George can you make me a chest of
drawers and he did now you might be
wondering what this object is and what
this object is here is what George made
but when you ask a maker to make a chest
of drawers they don't always do what you
think they're gonna do do you want to
see what he did
yeah thanks George best response of the
morning upstaged by the furniture and
within this little Chester drawers this
rather big manly chest of drawers is
well our three secrets to finding
confidence within three lessons that I
had to learn on the way now there's a
big lesson in here the last lesson is
the big one we're going to get there and
it's not what you might think it's a
lesson that might surprise you but first
would you like to see inside the first
drawer it's a bit delicate this so what
we have in here is an instrument because
as you've just been hearing the voice is
the most amazing instrument it's
magnificent
and how often do you think about how
yours works because like this little
guitar it has a string and it has a
hitter where's the string of your voice
hand on it here give it shakes your
larynx get everybody and then the hitter
is the air now when you know that your
voice is an instrument what does that
tell you
you know people come to me and they say
oh I've got a bad voice I'm not a good
speaker I get worried about this kind of
moment I hate meetings I hate
presentations can't do it the voice is
an instrument there's no such thing as a
bad saxophone as though because when we
hear a great saxophonist and he's
probably somewhere down here what we
know is that they've practiced a lot
that not only do they have talent but
also that they have worked and worked
and work to get a great sound now if you
ever doubt the sound of your voice let
me tell you all you have to do
is practice and when I was worrying
about that moment that I'm gonna call my
central hall of shame because it was
what I remembered was the story of a guy
in ancient Greece called demosthenes
that's a bit of a big old name so we're
gonna call him the Greek dude from now
on which actually is also a bit of a big
word so we might just call him Dave I
think now Dave was speaking at the
Assembly which is like the o2 we have
Simon in the room it's like the the
Brixton Academy of the Greek you know
ancient Greek world and he was feeling
pretty nervous he wanted to be an orator
you know orator 'he's were the rock
stars of their day and so he geared
himself up for this big moment at the
Assembly and you know what he bombed
they said he was uncouth in his speaking
and that he stammered and so the
audience jeered at him they threw stuff
please don't do that today and he left
that stage feeling so downcast when he
got a bit of advice from an actor
now I'm sure Greek actors were pretty
much the same as they are now and I'm
sure the actor was a bit like this but
what he said to him is you need more
expression in your voice you're just not
giving it enough welly enough energy and
you also need to believe in yourself
because the message is good so
demosthenes takes himself back home and
he goes for it this is his rocky moment
he builds himself an underground cellar
he shaves his head half of his head so
that he can't leave the house for three
months and then he practices for three
months solid in front of her a big
shield that's polished like a mirror and
when he's ready when he's up there he
goes out he goes to the sea and he
speaks over the waves so his voice has
to boom out over the waves and then he
goes back he goes back to the assembly
and he speaks again and he becomes known
as one of the greatest orators of his
day so what does that tell you it tells
you about practice the power of practice
now you might not want to shave off your
head
you might not want to build an
underground cellar because the council
might have words but what you can do is
practice and the simplest way to
practice is to sing you don't have to do
a big momma mom our voice coach warm-up
unless you want to but what I really
recommend is that every day sing
somewhere sing in the shower
sing in the car sing on the tube if you
feel brave I wasn't sir Thomas's
hospital for a blood test about two
weeks ago and there were two women's
singing in the space where the blood
tests were happening which was lovely so
I recommend it singing is the way to a
great voice practice is the way to a
great instrument so that's lesson one
and we have another drone which we're
gonna open in a moment but before we get
there I've got a question say walk into
a room okay you don't know anybody some
of you may have had that feeling this
morning how do you know who the most
powerful person in the room is the
person with the most confidence that in
a confidence that we're going for here
how could you tell how they carry
themselves that's lovely learner and you
you know you're you're in the same space
on you because you're a singer and it is
that how they carry themselves and
actually what an actor will tell you is
that it's about the breath the most
powerful person in the room has the most
relaxed breathing pattern and there's a
well-known scientist called Paul Ekman
who looks into emotion and he said which
would make actors love because it seems
so straightforward to them but maybe
isn't to science that he couldn't
understand why breath mattered for a
long time and he and his research has
explored it until he started to
understand that the unconscious system
you know I can't control my spleen is
just doing its own thing but I can
control my breathing and if I get into
my breathing I get into the
conscious I calm myself down so what's
within you is the key to this relaxed
confident power actors know this because
when actors are playing King the King
stays really still everybody moves
around the King and that's how you know
the Kings in charge the next time you
feel nervous about something try that
try getting still now within your body
is something that is really the king of
the body
it's what the Greeks called the center
of all expression and I bear that 50% of
this room have never thought about it
would you like to see what it is so
thank you my still handsome friend so
okay we've got our lungs haven't we
we've got this which is probably not an
anatomical representation of a heart but
it's nice but what's down here what's
this thank you very much
diaphragm it is indeed your diaphragm
now put your hands up if you have
thought about the diaphragm recently if
you put your hands up if you've thought
about your diaphragm today thank you
singers in the room good or actors or
sax not furnace put your hands up if you
haven't yet thought about your diaphragm
today yeah that is quite a large
percentage so we don't think about our
diaphragms do we but the diaphragm is
the key to regulating your system it's
how you calm yourself down in that
moment where you stand in front of all
the eyes it will make you feel confident
when you most need it and you least feel
like it now I didn't know anything about
my diaphragm I'd learnt about it I knew
what it was supposed to look like but I
didn't know how it felt and then one day
I was feeling really stressed I was
breathing up in my chest you know I had
that kind of squeaky high-voiced
adrenalin breeze
up in the chest not good and I walked
into a yoga class and the yoga teacher
said you look really stressed which is
never a good start
he said lie down on the floor and he lay
me down I closed my eyes expecting some
lovely relaxing yoga thing and suddenly
put a gym weight on my stomach and he
said breathe lift that and I did I
breathed in and as I breathe in I had to
lift that gym weight with my stomach and
my diaphragm shuddered into action and
suddenly I got it I got how it should
feel I got that I didn't need to breathe
up here anymore that I could breathe
down and I'd like to suggest that the
diaphragm is the king of confidence so
should we find yours we take it them and
take your thumb and just put it below
your bra strap yep that's right sir you
got it
that's it and just thumb there and just
gently push now Laurence Olivier when he
was taught to breathe Laurence Olivier
you know the actor was taught to breathe
by pushing a grand piano now I certainly
don't have a grand piano at home London
houses don't fit them these days are
they but we can all practice the feeling
of pushing a grand piano if you breathe
in and push your thumb away and now
breathe out and feel it push back so
you're filling up an air balloon in your
stomach now breathe then push your thumb
away now breathe out push it back
welcome to your diaphragm and if you put
your hands on your ribs your diaphragm
goes all the way around you can also
fill the ribcage as you breathe in so
feel the ribs open as you breathe and
close as you breathe out if you are ever
nervous about one of these moments do
that your diaphragm is the key to your
confidence so we've got two lessons
we've got the power of practice we've
got the importance of the diaphragm
there's a third lesson which is the big
one
it's the one that really makes a
difference and I started to think about
this lesson a couple of weeks ago
actually because someone I'd worked with
wrote to me she wrote me an email and
she said she'd been through the worst
possible thing that you can imagine
happening to someone she had just got
married and was on honeymoon when her
husband had a heart attack and died and
she had to go back to the church they
got married in and speak a eulogy for
this man in fact she also read a poem
that she'd written when they first met
and she said on the worst day of my life
I had to pull myself together I had to
find the energy of celebration for this
man that I really loved and the only way
to do it was what you taught me the
skills of breathing low and slow taking
my time getting the control finding the
inner calm
evidence it was the greatest gift I
could give him and there are moments in
our lives where we have to speak not
because we have something to say for us
but because we want to speak for someone
else a wedding a eulogy and I would
suggest that in those moments these
skills matter more than ever and what
you need to know in those moments is in
this drawer
it's breath
it's a
and why air masses it's because we
breathe our thoughts all speech is out
breath all song is out breath and all in
breath is thought just put a hand back
on that diaphragm for a moment and
breathe out and then feel the breath in
and as you breathe in think of someone
you really love now if we will all to
speak on that out-breath it would be
full of love now breathe in again and
breathe in a feeling of excitement for
the day that's gonna come because it's
gonna be so good and if we were to
breathe in and then speak on that
feeling then we have excitement in our
voices so you can control your voice
with the idea of breath is thought and
it's in Latin the two worlds ancient and
modern the Romans understood this
inspiration and respiration have the
same root the Romans understood that we
breathe our thoughts and because we
speak on the out-breath all you have to
think about is the in-breath and you
know the simplest way to think about the
in-breath close your mouth so who would
have thought that the big secret I
promised you was that if you want
confidence in speech all you have to do
is know when to shut your mouth
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
you